My name is Nicolás Rojas Castro. I’m anindependent
filmmaker from Chile. And I knew pretty early
on that I wanted to tell stories, hopefully
make movies, I was like 13 I guess.
And I went through high school and everything
and then I went to a pretty humble university
called Viña del Mar University where I studied
cinema (it’s like a film school) and I had
pretty good teachers (like screenwriting teachers)
and history teachers and cinema teachers who
taught you more the craft than to appreciate
the art itself. And in doing my University
days, I made a couple of short films and I
ended up in my career with a very ambitious
project. It was a very big movie about a real
life case that happened here in Chile about
some psychopaths. I actually shot 20 minutes
of the movie and turned it into some kind
of teaser and went to the contest that the
Government has to finance films and I didn’t
get it but I guess that was good because it
was a really big movie for me to take. I was
22 and really young.
But I got the opportunity to work with great
talent like big talented actors and I had
a great script and that kind of opened up
something for me that when I finished the
university I went on to make and independent
short film which I did and went to a couple
of festivals and got a few awards and a year
after that I set out to make my first feature.
I went to a lower scale of feature and in
the summer of 2013 I shot it. It’s called
DISTANCE (DISTANCIA) and I premiered it in
2015.
In the meantime when I was in post-production
of that film I switched cities and I came
to Santiago which is the capital of Chile
and started a job at University in a department
where I was in charge of making original content
where I developed a series of micro documentaries
and it has ten episodes, it’s about different
crafts that we are losing with time like shoemakers
and bicycle makers and stuff like that.
Then I made another project that consisted
of grabbing a few independent musicians from
Chile (a couple of them songs from theirs)
and gave them to illustrators, painted a picture
of the song in a canvas and that became a
series of music videos that was along with
along with the museum exposition of the art
itself.
And then I switched jobs and now I’m a director
of video content in big local radios from
Chile where I direct commercials and make
projects. Recently we premiered a documentary
about live music.
I guess the problem current and always issue
about an independent filmmaker is making the
time to actually do the work to pull off your
own projects (it’s hard when you have a
day job). Luck for me my day job also consists
of on having a camera on hand and trying to
develop stories so I’m not that away from
the craft itself but it’s still an issue
to make time, to get home and sit down and
actually get something written down for a
project that you’re trying to pull off on
your own.
Try not to let the day-to-day issues like
work, family, love life or whatever can come
up to get in the way of what you’re trying
to do because you actually have to be in a
very peaceful or sort of peaceful mindset
to actually get something done. It’s really
easy to start procrastinating and having a
lot of self-doubt and mainly issues with one’s
self like “I’m not good enough” or “Why
am I going to do this if it’s probably going
to turn out worse than the previous thing
that I did that didn’t actually turn out.”
But one is always it’s worse critic.
I think that the best way that you can deal
with such issues is you can is be super headstrong
and try not to be a perfectionist…in my
case I’m always trying to achieve, I’m
a real perfectionist. So it’s kind of hard
when you are halfway through a project and
you realize that it’s not what you originally
had it in your mind and you don’t find it
perfect and don’t put it aside. It’s actually
the work itself that you need to keep doing
so I guess the way I’m trying to deal with
these issues is I’m trying to do it no matter
what, no matter what the outcome is.
Even if I’m young, I know a lot of young
filmmakers you have to do the work. You cannot
achieve an amount of greatness in the craft
if you don’t actually do it. So I guess
you always keep on learning while you’re
doing so it’s really important to just push
through it and keep doing no matter what.
Don’t think about what’s coming next.
Once you get a job done and you put it out
there, it’s up to public opinion and public
opinion some time can but sometimes it doesn’t.
But that doesn’t mean that it has to condemn
the way you do things, you just have to keep
on doing them.
I think what is actually paralyzing in some
way is fear first of all (fear of failure).
But you can’t event begin to fail if you
don’t try. So I guess that the hardest thing
for me to do is to be that headstrong and
just keep on doing it no matter what just
sit down and I don’t know finish the screenplay
even if it’s not going to get made, just
do it. Maybe have like 10-20 screenplays locked
in a drawer until there’s going to be just
probably one (could be a short film, could
be a documentary, could be anything). But
one that will get shot and then eventually
is going to come up with other different issues
but you just have to finish every project
that you set your mind to do. I think that’s
really important because frustration is even
worse when you set out to start something
and you don’t finish it.
I don’t know if there are any filmmakers
out there that tend to deal with the same
issues that I do and I wonder what do you
do to overcome fear and keep pushing through?